Laura paedon joins us now along with
former White House press secretary Sean
Spicer mark I didn't really actually
expect you ever to be on the program not
kind of like we've been opposing each
other in many ways for many years I give
you a credit and it's not because you
agree sure we've never had ever this
happened to an American president ever
it's never been this bad
we got FISA lies we've got we have a
deep state we've got spies in a campaign
this is bad for the country explain what
you meant well I think that's exactly
right look I spent a year fighting Ken
Starr
when I thought that was wrong and a lot
of people here at Fox News herself
included were gung-ho on that and I saw
how destructive that process was to the
presidency the people around them and
how in the end it resulted in nothing
and today I looked at this process and
I'm a skeptical person that's at first
it seemed like it was a good process
maybe it made sense but as more and more
questions Kim came really to the fore
how did this get started what kind of
techniques were used what was behind the
warrant what kind of techniques did
these prosecutors use were there raiding
people and shaming them and threatening
relatives this doesn't seem like an
American democracy it seems like a Star
Chamber series of events and now this
thing is opening up after a year and
testimony by every one of these former
intelligence chiefs they never said that
they were using this kind of
intelligence they've been consistently
hiding what they were doing why they
were doing it whether a democrat or
republican I think more people have to
come together and say enough we can't
continue to criminalize politics I may
not agree with you or president Trump
and tons of mortgage but I will agree on
this is the way I've seen this unfold
listen if we are gonna have and and this
is no offense to Hillary the Clintons
you work with if she pays for Opera
research that's fine this part of
politics but a foreign national puts
together a dossier and in an
interrogatory in Great Britain says oh
that was raw intelligence maybe 5050 and
that becomes to use the Grassley grab
memo wording the bulk of information to
obtain a FISA warrant
three subsequent renewal applications
mark and then we've got spies in the
campaign that's not the United States to
me you even mentioned the deeps that you
use the term where we will lose the
country if the tools of intelligence are
turned on the American people this way
look I say the deep state appears to me
to be in a deep state of desperation
they know this I GE report is coming
down they know that noonas and others
have really been successfully getting to
the bottom of how this thing started and
they know this is all coming out and you
see these guys how they're changing
their stories from day to day how they
become TV Talking Heads
it's just really it's just incredible to
think that they headed our national
intelligence establishment you know I
think this is going to come down I think
this idea report I presume will not
comee out of the box as a potential
witness you know it'll change my mind
but that doesn't you know it's hard to
see how that's not going to come down
that way and Sean I would expect in the
end here a criminal referral but there's
never I am calling this the biggest
abuse of power corruption scandal in
history and it really when you think
about it look at what Watergate was a
break-in it ended up with the president
resigning and cover-up that ensued but
now we're talking about a sophisticated
operation spying on any campaign and
then of course lying to get a FISA
warrant the most difficult warrant to
get you had to lie before a judge time
after time and not telling them that
this is OP research paid for by the by
the other party right and I think the
other thing that's important to note you
talked about it in the package leading
up to this but the stories of both Comey
and clapper in particular have continued
to evolve and change as far as what
they've originally said happened and as
and what they say happened now and as
more information comes out whether it's
Devon Nunez or trey Gowdy or others that
are digging and getting into more and
more of these what happened more
questions are coming out that need to
get answers the president's right that
we need to get to the bottom of this
find out exactly what happened when it
happened who ordered it to happen and
why it was done but we continue to have
more and more questions come out the
more that people dig in and you look at
people like Devon
and trey gowdy Richard Burr in the
Senate the more people ask questions the
more they get attacked I think there's a
lot of people who are very concerned
about finding out the truth of what
happened last cycle why it happened and
who ordered it I I think Marc where are
your liberal friends this is interesting
because Alan Dershowitz and I agree with
them on some issues especially issues
involving the Middle East Israel our
closest ally where are those civil
libertarians that we that are supposedly
in the Democratic Party because their
voices have been silent is it just
because of political differences that
they're willing to accept this type of
intelligence abuse and abuse of power
and spying on other candidates well look
even organizations like the ACLU that
used to be for the First Amendment no
matter what have changed their policy
because you could raise a lot more money
being on one side or the fence or the
other
look I'm disappointed that more people
aren't concerned what's going on here
with the FAA it's not about this
president it is not about this campaign
it's about all campaigns of all
presidents as I said of the peace we
cannot allow the deep state to operate
in this manner we've got to really get
to the bottom of what's going on here
for sure so if you have taken him just
for writing the article wait till some
of your old friends see you on this show
god help you but thank you for what
you're doing I think it's courageous and
it's the right thing to do this is this
is a real real danger to the country
thank you sir Sean always good to see
you